Tại sao tạo ông của tục lục cao chật bánh đâm thẳng vào cửa hàng kến 2 người chết,
khoảng 40 mỡ mỡ mỡ biệt thương tại ITALI.
Tái nạn sẽ ra ngày 20, 2, theo AP, chuyển số chiến, trải giọc chủ via Lay,
Vitorio, Venetope và thông thường sẽ đi thẳng.
Tuy nhiên khi đến đoạn chuyển dài phục phục tiến khác,
răng tạo bất ngờ dễ xanh nhánh, lệ khỏi lộ chiến thường lệ số chật bánh.
Lực lượng cứ hộ đã đi ông mối巴 sẽ cứu thường đến hiện trường.
Hóan lại bị hướng họng nạn.
Hãy khách được đưa ra ngoài và quả quân chẳng giết trong lúc trở của trởi đế.
Theo 7 News, Thưa điểm xây dạ tên nạn, tầu trở kiến khách, dài khoảng 20 mỡ mỡ,
có thể trở tối đà sống y sống người.
Hãy trở mi lành VAPI Sala cho biết một đạn nhân từ vòng trên tầu,
người có lại bị tầu tông khi bản tầu trở bánh.
Diu trở bản đầu, kiến về lỗi thông tác liên quan đoạn chuyển dài.
Lên bị bản hành dốc thông cục gặp mi lần 18 mỡ,
cho biết đang phối hợp với các khoảng trinh năng để lạm sống người nhân.
Sự cố giễn ra trong thời điểm viên lăng,
tổ chức trụi sự kiện thời trang thămu.
Đông thời bước vào dài bản chuyển biện cho para linh pic của đông.